كان ما يقارب او ما يزيد عن 160 قارب في
منا دير البلح تم او انهاء 131 وحده زكريا
بكر ناشط مختص بقطاع الصيد مسؤول لجان
الصياد ويعتبر قطاع الصيد الثاني اهم قطاع
انتاجي الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي استهدف هذا القطاع منذ العام
2006 تحدثنا وبشكل واضح ان الاحت
الاسرائيلي يتعمد تدمير قطاع الصيد بشكل
ممنهج من خلال العمليات الملاحقه
والمطارده واطلاق النار وما ينتج عنها من
عمليات قتل واعتقال وتدمير ومصادره مراكب
حرب الحاليه
والتي يشنها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحق
ابناء شعبنا بالتالي اصين وبما انهم جزء
اصيل من الشعب الفلسطيني كان لهم حصه
الاسد من عمليات
التدمير يعني هيك زي ما انت شايف الدمار
الكامل مصدر رزقنا وحالنا البحر فش اي
حاجه غير البحر ولا بديل ولا شي غير الصيد
يعني لا شغله ولا عم هذا مال قرايبي ودار
عمي لا ضل حس ولا ضل مكان ولا ظل شي انه
الزوارق هلكتنا هلك
يعني ط ما وصلت للاخر للاخر معان سحبنا
حنا وين اجينا هنا قعدنا ليلتين ثلاثه
مرميين هنا على اسفلت بالشوارع ولا ولا
شرب ولا حاجه ولا حرامات الناس الله بعناد
الحلال ادونا حرامات وحتى لهنا احنا
الساعه خسه الساعه رضات اليهود اللي الشط
على البحر بخوا يعني بسمع الطخ عينينا
بنخاف نقوم واولاد مرشحين عيانين فيش
امال يعني المينا مدمره كليا هي مركب
محروقه هناك وهي مركب هذ مقصوفه وهذه
مقصوفه يعني باي لحظه باي لحظه ممكن احنا
نموت هان يعني دمار دمار دمار الخبط وين
بتروح
علينا نستطيع القول الان بانه لم يتبقى
قارب واحد في ميناء غزه لم يتبقى قارب
واحد في شمال قطاع غزه بل اكثر من ذلك
الاحتلال حول الميناء الوحيد في مدينه غزه
الى خراب من خلال تدمير غرف ومخازن
الصيادين بالكامل لو انتهت الحرب الان لن
يجد الصياد الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه وشمال
قطاع غزه ماير
داخل
البحر اع صيادين بعانوا كان بالاول من نقص
في ماده الفيبر جلاص التي تصنع منها
القوارب
من قطع الغيار للمكن كذلك المكان من 16 او
17 عام لم يدخل اصبح مهترئ بشكل كامل اذا
نتكلم عن 15000 شيكل لكل قارب بدون
شباكه
يعني بتتكلم عن نص مليون شيكل لحوالي 30
حسك نتكلم عن قطاع بحتاج الى ملايين
الملايين